the demand for cyber Security
Professionals has grown exponentially in
the last two decades and why aren't they
the numbers of cyber crimes has
increased every us sees a new zero day
vulnerability attack and more and more
devices are getting connected through
the internet in times like this it is
evident that more and more individuals
would want to go in the field of cyber
security and one of the most important
thought that such individuals have is
whether I should start applying for jobs
after learning the necessary skills or
should I get myself certified not only
that with over hundreds of cyber
security certifications out there from
vendor specific to generic and from
entry level to advance the confusion
just keeps on adding up but worry not
because we will entangle the confusion
web of cyber security certifications and
whether you should do it or not in this
video we will dive deep into
understanding whether you should go for
a cyber security certification or not
and if so then why and which one now
without any further Ado let's get
started if you are looking to embark on
a cyber security career Journey consider
the Celtic cyber security boot camp gain
essential skills and practical
experience to safeguard organizations
critical systems and sensitive data from
cyber attacks through real world
projects gain expertise in defensive and
offensive cyber security digital
forensics penetration testing and
infrastructure design with the caltex
cyber security bootcamp our curriculum
labs and Hands-On exercise provide
exposure to popular cyber security tools
meeting industry demand check out the
course Link in the description for more
details cyber security certifications
offer substantial advantages to those
experienced in cyber security at
beginner level including skill
enhancement expanded career
opportunities industry acknowledgment
and support for ongoing learning and
professional growth however it's
important to choose certifications that
align with your career goals research
their relevance and recognitions within
the industry and complement them with
practical experience and a commitment to
staying updated with evolving cyber
security practices so now cyber security
certifications are highly valuable and
worth pursuing for several compelling
reasons including industry recognitions
so these certifications are respected in
cyber security validating your expertise
and showcasing your commitment to
professional development this
recognition enhances your credibility
and marketability among employers client
and colleagues the next reason is skill
enhancement cyber security certification
offers specialized training in specific
areas allowing you to depend your
understanding of principles techniques
and Technologies this enables you to
develop Advanced skills in high demand
in the industry and then career
advancement obtaining cyber security
certification opens doors to a new
career opportunities and as straight
your career progression employers often
prefer certified candidates as
certification demonstrate Readiness for
higher level roles and responsibilities
and next we have stay current with
industry standards cyber security
certification require ongoing education
and renewal ensuring you stay updated
with the latest industry standards best
practices and emerging threats this
helps you to stay ahead in the rapidly
evolving field and the fifth reason is
professionally networking certification
often provide access to professional
communities and networking opportunities
engaging with fellow certified
professionals allow you to make valuable
connections collaborate and share
knowledge and the sixth reason is
personal and professional growth
pursuing cyber security certification
promotes personal and professional
growth it expands your knowledge on your
skills and present new challenges it
allows you to explore different areas of
cyber security and for straight lifelong
learning so by pursuing cyber security
certifications you can gain industry
recognition and enhance your skills
Advance your career stay updated with
industry standards build professional
networks and experience personal and
professional growth this reason makes
cyber security certification an
excellent investment for your career in
the field of cyber security and the top
companies hiring cyber Security
Professionals include American Express
Netflix Oracle Amazon LinkedIn Microsoft
Google VMware and many more cyber
security certificates validate your
expertise in specific areas of cyber
security and provide evidence of your
commitment to professional development
to Fast Track your cyber security career
visit simply learns website and explore
popular courses to help you enter the
field some recommended course include
certified ethical hacker certified
information system security professional
certified information system auditor
cism com Tia security and certified load
security professional evidently the
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is on the rise and is expected to
increase with this growing need numerous
career opportunities are available in
the cyber security field for individuals
with diverse backgrounds and skill set
now let's explore the salary ranges in
the cyber security field from entry
level to advanced level according to
Glassdoor the average annual salary for
a security analyst in the United States
is approximately 91 000 in India the
average early salary for a security
analyst is around 6 lakhs per annum the
mid-level position in cyber security is
commonly known as security engineer
according to Glassdoor the average
annual salary for a security engineer in
the United States is approximately 105
000 however in India it is 8 lakhs per
annum next the advance level position in
cyber security often includes roles such
as cyber security specialist according
to Glassdoor the average annual salary
for a cyber security specialist in the
United States is a approximately one
hundred and twelve thousand dollars
however in India it is 12 lakhs per
annum so with this we have come to the
end of this video I hope this video was
informative and interesting if you need
any help opting for this course please
let us know in the comment section below
we will get back to you as soon as
possible until next time thank you and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign